let's get into our conversation with a
Los Angeles native and an incredible
human being someone who can speak to
this city so much she wrote a real Love
Letter herself to this beautiful place
it's Billy eilish
I watched your documentary I've been
following you uh for as long as I can
remember
and there there's a moment in your
concert when you snap your ankle and you
you walk off stage and you come out
and this is one of the reasons why I I'm
so in love with you is because you say
look I just want to do it a certain way
and people don't know how to usually be
so honest in those moments
how do you just say it like it is how do
you know to do that that is such an art
you know I've always been very very
strong-willed and honest which I think
is like a blessing and a curse but
the funny thing is that
the older I've gotten the the less
confident I've gotten and it's it kind
of made me like
almost because I watched that I
rewatched the doc like a few weeks ago
and it made me cry because I was
thinking how like free-spirited I was
and how open-minded I was and then it's
like the media just like
it tears it away from you and it's like
it's not fun right now so it's like I'm
trying I know I know I'm trying to like
I don't know but believe me I get it
I and I and I have such faith that you
will because even when you're struggling
you're aware of the struggle
um you said something that really struck
me in the documentary you you really
have this issue with the word fans
and I was wondering where that stems
from I think that the reason that it was
so weird to me was because
one moment I was a fan and then suddenly
I was looked at as this like higher up
Suddenly even when I was 14 and it was
so weird because I was like I'm not even
anyone I just make music and these kids
that I feel like I already know suddenly
like oh they're Billy's fans and then
there's Billy and so that's why it was
so weird to me but I think of them as
like literally my skin like part of me
and like how I get through stuff and you
know they always have my back and like
they're fans because just as much as I'm
a fan but that doesn't make them any
less than me or anybody else you know
now one of the things that I'm also so
in love with you for is your directing
why did you know that you would be the
one to take control and get your vision
across
I mean I've always I've I've always had
the ideas already I just didn't really
know that I could do them myself for a
while but then after a while I was just
like you know what
I want to do this because I think I've
realized that this is what I've wanted
to do all along
and I can actually like I have to prove
myself and I really had to prove myself
because who's going to trust a little 15
year old kid that doesn't have any
experience at all but I did and it's
been like someone did yeah the best
decision ever ever ever and kind of like
you know do you know Pippi Longstocking
yeah
hell yeah shoot the Go-Go's beauty and
the beat album and Pippi Longstocking
were like these two things that collided
in my world when I was a little girl
right here in Los Angeles and they both
showed me that like I could do anything
it didn't matter that I was a girl and I
didn't have to become a man or a man
hater I could be all things girl but I
could do anything yeah and
um I loved how personal you were about
the
marketing and putting out of your album
how are you feeling about this album
being out there now
how does it feel
s good I was very very nervous uh and
very worried and anxious
um because also you know
sophomore album is like
has more pressure than the first one
because especially if people really
liked the first one and it's my favorite
thing in the world and I
have so much
trust and love shoved into this project
and I I mean it's terrifying that it's
out in the world it's like couldn't be
scarier to me but I am also very happy
and pleased and hope that you know
people can actually listen to the lyrics
and actually understand them and
listen to me
um and contribute it to their own life
and like put it in their own situations
and like
I hope that it helps people and like
just makes them make a difference in
their life and change something in their
life that's been bothering them or
something because that's what music is
for well I love you and I will be going
to bed tonight as I usually do playing
the PJ party video in my head and
usually I'm there with you girls like oh
my God can we just
can we just be best friends
please I would love it I love you so
much this is an insanely like surreal
interview I don't know why it's a big
deal for you because it's an insanely
enormous deal for me and you're
Drew Barrymore so shut up
thank you guys so much thank you thank
you thank you
of them happier than ever is available
now and accompanied by her cinematic
Concert Experience happier than ever a
love letter to Los Angeles which is
available on Disney plus I'm going to
say something directly to Billy you
deserve to be happier than ever it is a
privilege to watch you on your journey
you bring tears to my eyes at how much I
love you thank you for allowing me to
have a great conversation with you
[Music]
foreign